wie alt sind eigentlich die deutschen
youtuber dass uns dieses verfährt so
häufig wie die schnauze halten
ich habe letztens gegen wie in meinem
fall den videos von surfen video gesehen
wo der holzklotz so nett gemacht hat und
das haben wir auch schon sehr viele
andere youtuber gemacht deswegen nennt
mich ruhig nachmacher hinzog
ich hole dann nebenan nach dem video ist
auf jeden fall eine website wo man
bilder googeln kann von bestimmten
leuten oder man kann eigene bilder
auswählen und dann sagt wieso website
einem quasi wie all diese person auf dem
foto geschätzt wird ist ja an sich nicht
so schwer aber ich habe übrigens weiter
an
das ist eines der alten 5 oder denkt
gruppe die am ersten zwölf neue der in
die kabine schöpfung de kommen am ersten
zwölf neue rein das ist so ein
olivfarbenes sprint also bis dann [ __ ]
schwierig den so hinzukriegen wir haben
sogar schon die street parade wird das
mal ein bisschen gefällt euch nicht mir
egal mir gefällt er mit welchem youtuber
fangen wir jetzt am besten an ich würde
ich am liebsten meine lieblingsfilme
anfang deswegen gebe ich mal kontra fda
dort ein und die website spucken ja wow
danke daran wird jetzt also mein alter
gemessen wir klicken einfach mal auf
jugenddisco und sv rieden kreuth geld
leiht wieso ich sehe doch voll jungen
drauf aus ich nehme jetzt mal einfach
das was links daneben ist also use
d'escoto 27 27 degas weil so zum
verständnis ich bin 20 27 ist schon eine
harte beleidigung die mir jetzt einfach
mal das foto von hier vorne da war ich
glaub ich 17 also youtube spot u 23 des
jahres liegt 320 sehe ich so fucking alt
aus ohne spaß ich muss mich letztens im
saturn ausweisen weil ich den film
kaufen wollte
das war harry potter ab 16 23
die bilder sind ja auch alle recht alt
also ich gehe jetzt mal laser luca ein
und versucht jetzt mal ein foto zu sehen
das hier ist doch schon so ein bisschen
neuer news co2 und ok ok
egal ich gehe das ist wirklich okay okay
ich bin wieder da ich bin wieder da
keine sorge keine sorge ich glaube kann
hat sich sorgen gemacht 32 dich ja
wahrscheinlich fliegen flugzeuge seit
neuesten direkt überm boden hermi werden
love me oh gott wer macht so was wir
niemals dieses foto von mir also ich
glaube da war ich im 18
justus rav4 geht er überhaupt unter 23
mal ich habe jetzt ein bild rausgesucht
von lukas krieger und der ist glaube ich
sechzehn oder siebzehn oder so um den
dreh und ich nehme das mal dieses foto
von ihm italiener ausrief news fotolia
das am 19
diese website schätzt ein immer circa
doppelt so alt dass anwälte er sich ohne
spaß nimmt ihn nicht nur kannst du
siehst du aus wie 12 justus foto 26 der
gab dennoch dem kind gesehen nichts
gegen brawngp ich finde das sieht schon
recht alt aus weil er halt barth hat und
einfach dieses markante gesicht und so
weiter und so fort wir nehmen
beispielsweise jetzt mal dieses foto
hier vom bromacker 38 okay da das ist es
ich weiß nicht wie alt krank ist also
keine ahnung ob das oder ist das nur
waffe wieder so ähnlich aus
würde ich erst mal so gut behaupten
daneben beispielsweise mal was kommt
demnächst recht ich bin der sonnenbrille
und nur minecraft skins ok alles klar
es sind sehr sehr wenig bilder hier von
sturm waffe also ich denke ich ihnen
dann wirklich einfach mal dieses
ich weiß nicht wie alt es ist aber er
sieht ein und ok 31 ich meine dass es
irgendwo noch verständlich aber dann ist
so ein lukas riga der auf dem bild
suchen ich zwölf war oder so wie das
auch unser 20 geschätzt
wer hat euch entwickelt microsoft der 2
vettel ist die youtube trends gegen die
letzten tagen das video von abu raed und
der moschee wo die 24 stunden im kino
waren was aber übelster fake war also
das war alles in dem spiel die waren da
irgendwie bald 24 stunden sondern nur
ein paar stunden und der alarm war nicht
echt und da war keine polizei suchen tv
und sehr viele andere haben darüber sehr
reflektierte videos gemacht und auch bei
den filialen angerufen und da sind schon
anzeigen raus und das alles aber ich
wollte einfach mal schauen wie alt diese
leute eigentlich an der website
geschätzt werden die leute die sowas
machen schätzt sich eigentlich ca
aufgefüllt 5a pol/red wird geschätzt auf
32 ok auf anderen bildern ist er 27 hier
ist er 29 ich habe gerade mal gegoogelt
also es angeblich 23 oder 24 da waren
ein paar verschiedene antworten also das
ist gar nicht mal so falsch daneben leon
maschinist hat ihren fotos des foto 30
okay ich glaube jetzt jetzt nicht 30
weil zecken slate gibt leon google ein
das erste was kommt droht den youtuber
nun das gefängnis ihr habt es geschafft
leute so macht man guten content leona
ist angeblich 22 also hat die website
ihnen auch deutlich älter geschätzt wie
nehmen wir noch andere bilder wie
beispielsweise
da ist ein 37 degas wahrscheinlich lügen
alle im internet oder marschiert
wirklich soll der hat echt richtig
witzig gewesen wenn die website jetzt
einfach gesagt hätte 5 oder so von wegen
geistiges alter wir können uns erinnern
dass sie haben maschine auf dem bild
gerade auf 37 geschätzt wurde deswegen
nehme ich jetzt mal das gleiche foto nur
ein bisschen kleiner jeder ist der 28
ich bin gleich ein foto wird einfach mal
kelly müssten die log ein gegeben weil
das mit mich selber interessieren die
aldi geschätzt wird nämlich auf 27 auch
ihr seid ihr denn bescheuert die sieht
hier überall aus wie 18-20 finde ich ein
bild von mir was auch auf 20 geschätzt
wird ja wahrscheinlich das bild ok mal
schauen wollt ihr mich komplett
verarschen 74 ich verstehe das nicht
woran machen sie das fest ich habe
einfach nur meine schnauze auf dieses
bild ist gerade mal drei monate her dass
könnte man sogar noch auf meinem
instagram account relativ weit oben
ich stehe jetzt einfach mal auf youtube
fast alle gerade 20 also ich bin 29
aber 74 wohin ich will mich einfach noch
einmal auf 20 schätzen lassen okay hier
bin ich 25 soll das war bei einem
geburtstag kommt kein bild gefunden
werden hier bin ich wer ist dieses
mädchen das ist so ein typisches pädo
bild alter da sitzt schon 33 jährige auf
eine zehnjährige gott wo führt das hin
luca 20 hat seine pizza verloren use
this photo 34 ja wahrscheinlich oder und
wem soll ich da noch das als er
nachschauen
ja denn dumm weil ich habe gerade dieses
video geschnitten und die letzte aussage
gerade wahrheit noch die augen leuchten
noch nachschauen oder aufnahme war
irgendwie vorbei und die ganze zeit
schon so gefragt wieso geht denn die
tonspur irgendwie 27 minuten durch den
aufnahmen oder 17 minuten auf das
darunter geschnitten auf irgendwie
sechseinhalb oder sieben minuten bin ich
glaube mich gerade und andere hat
einfach wohl nicht mehr aufgenommen auch
broadcaster wahrscheinlich aber alles
gut
ich werde hier einfach jetzt noch
weitermachen also ich hab da noch julian
haben nachgeschaut das ist sie sogar
noch gespeichert in der suche da kann
man dieses quote mit der gasmaske dann
haben wir nächstes foto geklickt dann
wurde nichts gefunden er die maske auf
hatte dann habe ich danach glaube ich
dieses ziel genommen wo er relativ jung
aussah und da wurde er sogar auf 18
geschätzt war dann glaube ich nämlich
sogar das jüngste alter was wir in dem
video hatten jedenfalls würde ich sagen
sie machen jetzt nur noch ein bisschen
weiter weil ich habe das heute morgen
aufgenommen und jetzt schon 12 uhr
abends aber ich habe jetzt gedacht
kommen
das ist doch sonst habe ich doch kein
richtiges video endet euch ihr habt mir
zu gucken ich gebe jetzt einfach mal
hier oben rein um zu schauen wie als er
geschenke used as rom 23 23 ds über 23
eur gbp ist nicht 23 sondern 27 jahre
alt aber er würde jünger geschätzt kind
halt nur krass wie das von foto zur foto
variiert auf diesen fotos beispielsweise
ok auf 23 auf diesem foto ist er 21 hier
ist er 27
so ist es immer die gleiche person
einfach wisst ihr wenig jetzt mal suche
den ältesten menschen der welt diese
frau ist york
ich weiß nicht wie sie ausgesprochen wir
da macht auch ziehen da gerade die
glaubt für die pds 122 geworden muss man
mal schaffen wir nehmen
einfach mal das foto hier von ihr und
sie ist kein gesicht erkannt hier nehmen
dann einfach mal dieses foto von ihr da
ist 790 kann sogar sein dass die da
gerade 90 war auf diesem foto hier ist
sie 71 das könnt sogar auch noch sein ob
diesem foto ist die 46 dann bin ich
sieht allerdings schon ein bisschen
älter schätzen hier würde ich sie selber
so auf 80 schätzen dort ist die 82er
website
das ist nicht schlecht gerade was du
ablieferte jetzt einfach mal katja
kramer witzige eingegeben die ist ja
dafür bekannt dass ich so ein bisschen
genauso was so ein bisschen provokant
hier nehmen beispielsweise einfach mal
die das foto oder wird sie auf 28
geschätzt ich glaube die sca so alt wie
ich gegen diese 20.000 sie sogar 37
gehen wir weiter hier vorne ist sie 24
hier vorne ist sie können direkt an die
faces das hier sind ihre brüste da ist
auch kein gesicht vorhanden
was kann man denn noch nehmen ich denke
dass hier
da ist kein gesichts dann nehmen wir mal
dass ich doch das ist von der kredite
sieben jahre 77 ich hab ja mal diese
kein delikt challenge reaction den rumpf
hochgeladen das verlegen ich gleich in
der hand hat mal und ich glaube das hat
sich hier gemacht und sie ist einfach
fucking 7 aber naja wenn die webseite
das sagt dann muss es stimmt das was ihr
vom video meine damen und herren ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen lassen auf
jeden fall mal leicht aber endlich getan
hat und bei 700.000 hinaus dieser
apfelsaft apfel orange und die ist leer
der treffer ist meine lampe umgefallen
glaube ich muss ein bisschen leise sein
weil die nachbarn nebenan hören dass
immer sehr krass und ich glaube das
schlafen schon aber ihr seht hier auf
jeden fall ein smiley eingeblendet da
könnt ihr mir ein kanal abonnieren
vermutlich weil ich schon so ne scheiße
lass es lieber sein mit einem abo und
hier findet ihr meine reaktion auf die
keine zeit also dass wo katja glaser
witz gerade auf sieben jahre alt
geschätzt wurde